you have an
admiration for mike tyson i love him
i'm just gonna let that sit for a brief
moment um
why i think there's a combination of
factors one is like
the timeliness of his career and like
the age i was
when he like came to prominence um
the raw brutal violence
and the raw brutal honesty when he
speaks
i think it's easy for people to hear him
or see his life
and cast him aside as some simian-esque
uh
like just [ __ ] scourge on society
but when you hear him speak like this is
not a guy who's unintelligent
this is a guy who knows himself better
than probably most of us know ourselves
it's disarming and uh you know that's a
humongous part of
my admiration for him
who is mike tyson because you there's it
feels
like there's similarities between him
and you there's a
it feels like there's a violent person
in there
but also really kind person and they're
all like living together in a little
house and you're the same there's a
thoughtful person
but there's also a scary violent person
and they're like having a picnic
they're having a picnic i think there
are dialectical tensions in everyone
these like
opposing forces yeah that are constantly
pulling at you
and at different points in your life
like it's sliding scale
and i think that uh certainly
when i was a younger person there was a
lot more
manifestation of the violence and a lot
less
of the kindness um people who were not
as close to me probably saw more of the
violent side and only the very close
people to me saw like
what would pass for the kind side and
now that's sliding in the other
direction
uh and i i worry actually sometimes that
there could be a situation where i need
that the old version of me
and he's getting further and further
away and i can't call him up if i need
him
and that that concerns me to it to a
certain degree
the sad aging warrior seeing his greater
self fade away
like but you still compete is that that
person return it seems like for mike
tyson that person returned at the
prospect of competition
it returns but i've learned i've learned
better how to
manifest it in competition in terms of
like the effects that that type of
emotion has on you physically in the
middle of a competition
so i've better learn how to utilize that
energy
but i think another side effect of this
is like having a gym where you're
a bigger guy and you're the head
instructor you can't be as mean and
violent as you once were
because you're also now trying to run a
business and
you spend so long so many so many years
trying not to be mean and
to you know soften your your technique a
little bit
that that all of a sudden just becomes
who you are and and i don't necessarily
like that so i've been trying to reclaim
that a little
bit on the mat but
i think in competition
there's there has to be
an athlete really wants to score the
points
a fighter really wants to incapacitate
you and put you in a position where they
can
do their own bidding and the result in a
jiu jitsu match might just still be two
points
but the motivations are very very
different what do you make of
tyson on joe rogan saying that he was
aroused by violence do you think that's
insane do you think that's deeply honest
for him and do you think that rings true
for
many of us others who practices in
different degrees
i don't i can't speak for a lot of
people and i think that
it's was a brutally honest statement by
him and i think it's something that
even if a lot of people feel it they're
not that comfortable
admitting it or saying it yeah but i
think
like there's there is great joy
in like landing a flush right hand on
someone's
jaw and then watching them crumble you
don't even feel it
you ever play baseball as a kid you can
hit a base hit off the end of the bat
and it will sting your hands
because of the way that you hit it you
can hit a home run
and you won't feel anything and it'll
just feel so good in your hands and
that's i think that
like one of the the joys of uh
physical contact when you do it the
right way and that goes for all physical
contact
when you do it the right way the
physical pleasure you can derive from it
and the mental pleasure it's uh
it's unparalleled
you